well the woman suspected of hitting and
killing a 48 year old tow truck driver
tuesday
went before a judge for the first time
today now she faces multiple charges
after police say she left the scene on
the 215 near decatur
detectives say it was an anonymous tip
that led to her arrest
8 news now spoke with her son today and
sasha loftis joins us now live near the
crash site
with more on
denise and bryan the son of coletta
spain said his heart is with
ryan billett's family as they just
really process this devastation
after ryan died here along the 2 15 on
tuesday night
i truly believe i don't think she knew
that she killed the truck driver
one day after her arrest coletta spain's
son
is speaking out she was you know crying
and kind of devastating and checking out
about the whole situation
jordan de spain asked us not to show his
face
but wants the community to know his mom
like he does
i don't think she really believed that
she even did that i don't
think my mom would just pull off from a
scene like that she's a pretty moral
person she's christian
my favorite is not the scene of accident
resulting in death the 51 year old faced
a judge
thursday after police say she hit and
killed tow truck driver
ryan billet along the 215 near decatur
tuesday night
then left the scene when she got home i
saw the damage i couldn't even open the
passenger door
she was limping her ankles are swollen
jordan says
his mom doesn't deny the crash but
claims it happened differently
i'm over here just shaken up about those
situations because i got a child away
and you know
she was excited to be in child's life
now he says his family is just
trying to move forward and their hearts
are with billet's family
as they face this unimaginable grief
she told my sister to pray for the
family
of the tow truck driver of course
now we have spoken to the family of ryan
billett they said that they just aren't
ready to speak to us
on camera at this time again as they
process this unimaginable grief
now as for coletta spain she is being
held tonight
without bail and among those charges she
faces include failure to stop
at the scene of a crash involving death
reporting live along the 2 15 tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now